Alexi reznikov forged bonds with
Canadian ministers and those of Allied
Nations over the last
558 days of Russia's full invasion now
Ukraine's charismatic defense minister
is out
there he must be held accountable for
what he has done while holding the
position of Defense Minister says this
soldier in Kiev raznikov has not been
named directly but allegations of
corruption including military
recruitment officers taking bribes and
mismanagement of funds have plagued the
defense department
the Ukrainian president was elected on
an anti-corruption platform on Sunday he
said the ministry needed a new approach
this international relations professor
says the president had to act but now
there has been a congruential factors
increasing the satisfaction in the west
particularly in the United States and
especially in the cases of your body as
to how the vast funds that are being
sent to support Ukraine are being spent
rustam umarov is the replacement and is
seen as clean with no links to
corruption and is a Crimean tartar
it's a way for assistant to reach out to
the Islamic world and say we are finding
a battle that is against imperialism
that is directed against Ukraine as a
country but also one that is denying the
right of the Tata minority the Muslim
minority with umarov tapped as the new
defense minister it could also be taken
as a sign that Ukraine will not give up
the fight to reclaim Crimea Crystal
commencing Global News London